[Music]
they are images
and sounds familiar to medics around the
world right now
but this is gaza
where the ability to treat the
coronavirus is so much harder
in this blockaded and overcrowded
enclave it is a daily battle
at gaza city's al ramal clinic they are
testing as much as they can
it is the same story everywhere the more
you can test the more you can isolate
the more chance you have of containing
the virus
but the vaccine is the real way out of
this and here they could be months away
from receiving it
yet just 50 miles away at israel's main
airport
the latest consignment of vaccine
arrived at the weekend
the israeli prime minister on hand to
receive it this
is the uncomfortable politics of vaccine
procurement
because in israel the world's most
efficient vaccine program is underway
twenty percent of the population has
already had it but in the palestinian
territories
the number vaccinated is zero the
israeli minister of health told
sky news it is not up to israel to
provide the vaccine to the palestinian
territories
why is that why are you not helping them
well i think that
we've been helping our palestinian
neighbors uh
from the very early stages of this
crisis
uh including medical equipment including
medicine including advice
including supplies uh i don't think that
there's
anyone in this country whatever his or
her views might be that can imagine that
i would
take a vaccine from the israeli citizen
and with all the
good will give it to our neighbors
israel controls entry to the west bank
and gaza as you pass through the
disparity in the quality of every aspect
of life is clear
the health system here must rely on
united nations support
dr ali abed rabbo is the director of
preventative health at the palestinian
ministry of health
as occupying force i think
and i believe that israel have
the commitment to procure the vaccine
for the palestinian population it's true
that according to the geneva convention
an occupying power is responsible for
healthcare
but the oslo peace accords signed by
yasa arafat three decades ago
handed responsibility for health and
plenty more
to the palestinians the problem is
oslo was supposed to be temporary a road
map to a proper state of palestine which
has never come
israel remains ever present there is
fault
and stubbornness on both sides
of the palestinians asked israel for
help with the vaccine
no it should they say be offered by the
occupying power
back in gaza the funeral of their latest
victim
abdul kareem was 61 years old
officials here are unwilling to ask for
israel's vaccine but would be unlikely
to get it now even if they did
they say their own procurement of jabs
will come in the next few months
mark stone sky news in jerusalem